Yeah.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for Monday.
Yeah.
September 10th, 2018. How's it going?
How I yeah. Oh, why? Yeah. Um,
I am back from a whirlwind tour.
I fucking crazy weekend.
I'm actually sitting here a
podcasting in front of the TV,
which I know a lot of you don't like.
Simply the fucking Steelers
and browns had a tie.
Wow.
Jesus Christ one that,
this exact reason why you don't like it.
This is the exact fucking
reason cause I get distracted.
I haven't seen a fucking tie since like
they've had over time. I don't really,
I don't recall one,
um,
zero zero and one of the Pittsburgh
Steelers and the Cleveland browns.
How about that? Um, anyways,
yeah, I'm sitting here.
I've got the Red Sox game
on in the background.
The Houston Astros are trying to become
the second team this season to sweep the
red sox while Boston is trying to go
two for two today against the city of
Houston.
All right.
Now we already done kicked the
shit at you fucking football team.
Now we're trying with the baseball
team. I'll be honest with you. Uh,
I thought the Patriots, so it's good for
the first two and a half quarters. Um,
special teams is letting up
more yards than I would like.
Then you would like bill you
as a what a football coach.
You as a comedian and a shit joke telling
fucking jackass who decided to fucking
record a game and fast forward
through the commercials yet. Bill,
what did you see on your
game film? Um, fair enough.
Fair enough. You know, there's
always room for criticism.
Who am I to sit here and
act like I'm above it? Um,
yeah, I thought I was very
impressed with our pass rush.
I was very impressed with our ability
to, uh, contain, uh, what's his name?
Watson there.
I thought he was going to be a nightmare.
I also thought he might've been a little
gun shy about running because he is
coming back from a knee injury. So I
thought when he ran, when he had to,
but I was impressed with him staying
in the pocket. Um, I liked, uh,
the new, uh, left guard. We
got there. I left tackle,
I should say taking over for Nate soldier,
soldier, I'll be you say his name.
He was only there for fucking 20 years.
Now he's playing with the giants. Um,
Brown, whoever that guy was just
keeping all those beasts up front.
Four of the Texas where they get clowny,
they got JJ watts and then they got some
other guy like maniac or something like
that.
Like his name is literally like,
it's like psycho or maniac or something
like that. I'm not a nickname.
The name he was born with as a baby.
Oh look at that little cute baby.
What's its name? Clarence Maniac.
You want to have a play date? Uh,
no I don't.
Why am I fucking head phones?
Fucking God damn these fucking
cheap ass fucking things.
I swear to God,
I just can't win.
Yeah.
CanNot fucking win. What is going
on now? This is all brand new shit.
I got all brand new shit. Hear people.
Speaking of which, if you want to fucking,
if you want to, a couple of things I'm
selling. I just bought a new mixer.
Uh,
my old one works fine,
but I'm getting back to doing
these uninformed with Joe de Rosa,
which is going to be up on my patrion
page coming up here in November.
We're going to take some episodes,
get a little in the can and that
type of shit and some other stuff.
So I didn't get a mixture where I could
actually have enough microphones for
more than two people.
So I have a mixer with the
chords and all of that shit. Uh,
if you want to start your own podcast,
if you want to open up your little
podcast shop across the street and compete
with me, uh, let me
know. I'll figure it out.
Cause I already started Dean
del Ray cell and some shit.
I got a drum kit that I'm selling.
All right,
I'll get all the information. I'll have
it posted on my fucking Twitter site. Um,
I'm selling this, uh, one of those
sonar, like travel kits. You know,
it's Kinda like the uh, Questlove
one. The, the, what is it? Uh,
whatever that one that he does with
the little fucking 18 inch bass drum.
It's the same thing, but just
sona. Um, and fucking beautiful.
I just don't have the room for it anymore.
I got a,
I made a little drum room in my,
uh,
garage so I don't have to have
a studio space for my drum son.
I brought the big boy kid home
and I got that little one,
which fucking sounds great by the
way. And I also have the, uh, the,
the fucking pads there where it's silent.
You know what I mean? Where it doesn't,
it doesn't, uh, you know, the Mesh ones
or the real ones. I got a tuned up.
Nice. My buddy tuned it
up, I should say, um,
after I kind of fucked it up a
little bit, but um, whatever,
that's what it's come down to
people. This is the new me. Okay.
I'm getting rid of Shit and right now
you know what my, my whole fucking day,
my headphones out work at right now.
I have no fucking idea if you can,
all I'm doing is just looking
at the fucking mixture.
I know that you can hear me. I haven't
been able to, I fucking came home.
I went to watch the fucking patriots game.
Uh,
my wife Angel that she is taped the
game for me and then I'm sitting there
watching it and it, the thing
just like, it starts fucking up.
Then I got to hit pause. I gotta shut
it off. I've got to turn it back on.
It was doing like one of those
fucking things and it started off.
It was doing it every couple of minutes.
Then once a minute I'll fuck you.
You can't fall ball foul ball.
Is that fair or foul? Five. All right.
Sorry. Um, it's two to one
red socks by the way. Astros'
her up. You just hit one down
by the Pesky Pole. It went foul.
Um,
anyways,
so then it started doing it like every
30 seconds and it was like every eight
fucking seconds. And I was loving
watching the game. Tony Romo,
I'm calling it right now. Tony Romo.
If he fucking keeps doing this shit,
he's going to be a hall
of fame broadcaster.
I have never learned more shit
about football.
I don't think.
Maybe since I'm going back
maybe to like John Madden,
the way the guys breaking down all of
this stuff and there's always been all
these coaches and all this
shit tried to do it somehow.
The Way Tony Romo does it, it's like
you get it and he does it in real time.
Um, it's fucking amazing.
So I was enjoying that.
So you know how the world works out?
What are you enjoying something? Well,
let's fuck up the recording of it.
So that's what ended up happening.
And um,
you know what it's funny about my
fucking headphones is if I sit up and I'm
uncomfortable, they work perfect. But
if I lean back and I'm comfortable,
I swear to God, dude, I don't
know what the fuck I think I did.
I kill Tesla and another fucking life.
Is that what I did?
And this is my fucking punishment.
Yeah.
This is literally all brand new shit.
I swear to God.
I don't know what the fuck I did.
I kick Edison in the balls
during a previous level.
He's a fucking thief anyways.
Right? I, I swear to God,
unbelievable. And this is the shit, right?
My wife never flips out about
shit like this. You know why?
Cause it never happens to her cause
she buys new shit and it works.
My wife will like lose her cell phone
and grand central station and then I'll
call it and they'll just be some
guy. Yeah. Yes I have it. No, no.
I'll bring it to you. Right? I lose
my cell phone. That's fucking it.
Over cold case file. No leads, no nothing.
That fucker is gone. All right,
so it's better over here.
Little better over here.
A little better.
Hmm.
Now this fucking thing
is hanging off here.
This whole fucking podcast is just gonna
be me bitching about this fucking wire
that I just bought. Now it's off.
Now it's off. Now it's on. Oh, I see.
What happens when there's a little bit
of weight and it's hanging down or can't
handle that can you can't fucking
handle a little bit of fucking weight.
Is that what it is? I just figured what
out what it is. Oh, we got a quitter here.
Everybody.
We got a little fucking snowflake.
Let's just move the whole
fucking table for you buddy.
Everybody gets a fucking ribbon
on my mixer.
Just fell off the fucking table.
This whole thing,
this is going off the rails here.
Okay.
Why do I try to make my life easier?
It doesn't work out. So I uh,
can
I lean back in the old man,
put his fucking back up against the couch.
Hello, test. Oh, there we go. There
we go. All right, so I'm back.
Why don't you just dem,
what'd you just saw?
That was why my wife is
sick of living with me.
I know everything's a fucking
conspiracy theory with me.
I really wish when those sort of
challenging moments and in the first world
country as a blue eyed white male,
that was actually a challenging moment
for me as people are there are like
literally swing war torn
fucking countries haven't,
God knows what Don to them,
right?
If there is a god and he's looking
down right now and he hears all this
screaming and yelling and shit
about stuff that's going on
and you find out what's this,
what's this poor soul screaming about
right after he slips at the horrors of war
and he's going to just see some bald 50
year old fucking moron doing a podcast
by himself yelling
about a microphone cord.
He's just going to look down and
it is a he, by the way. All right.
Fuck all this feminist shit where now
they turn in everything around, you know,
fuck this. You know, there's
gotta be something that has
to still be a guy, right?
Why Not God,
Oh, why do I love being an
asshole? I just, I enjoy it.
I'm sorry. I do. All right.
He's going to be looking down and be like,
Oh, who is that? I made that. All right.
Do me a favor when he passes
yet to give them the, uh,
tell him to take the down escalator.
MMM.
[inaudible]
I don't know where I'm
going to go when I die.
I can't even think about that shit.
I watched that Mr. Rogers, uh,
won't you be my neighbor?
Did you fucking see that?
You guys watch that thing? Whatever
you call it, their documentary.
I have never felt like such a piece of
shit in my life after watching that.
He's definitely fucking Weirdo man.
He's so fucking weird,
you know, says the guy by himself losing
his shit. Talking into a microphone.
I had the nerve to say that
this guy's weird, but um,
I I, yeah, fuck it. Take it easy.
End of the getting gunned down. Um, sorry.
Anyways, I a, I watched that
documentary and uh, Fred Rogers.
Mmm Mike.
I said if this, if, if there is
a god and Christians are right
and God at his son without
having sex with a virgin.
MMM Jesus.
I mean, just, how do you even say
it out loud and still believe it,
man. It's just clearly written by
guys who don't want sloppy seconds,
you know? So then they got to have to
have like that. Like she's a virgin.
No one ever banged her before,
so she doesn't know what good sex is.
She doesn't know what a big Dick is.
Now I could feel comfortable to mount
this person. I mean, is that, is that,
was that the underlying theme of
all of that? Huh? Hey, look at that.
That's sort of a feminist look at
it, isn't it? I Dunno what it is.
[inaudible] right now.
I'm sorry.
My apologies to everybody.
South of a fucking Washington
DC Mason Dixon line there.
Do you guys know the first, you
know the Gettysburg address? Yeah,
I had no fucking idea where that was in
the first fucking battle of the civil
war. I thought it was like, you know,
somewhere in the sec they
were in big 10 country.
They weren't fucking Pennsylvania. I had
no idea. We never would get that far.
We always start with those fucking
three ships. The Nina, the Pinta,
the Santa Maria, they came over.
They somehow, they came over after a
Columbus, right? Columbus
came over to like,
I dunno, like Cuba.
Well The Bahamas, Haiti,
he was down around there. Right. And
then the Nina, the Pinta and Santa Maria,
they all came over together. Right.
Sort of the first carnival cruise.
It's kind of like that
without, you know, a workout,
Roman scurvy and shit like
that. Right. Big Dope buckles.
They must send a credible
neck muscles back then. Huh?
Big fucking hat with that belt on there.
Looking down at your soggy fucking
boots, bringing your head back up. Um,
anyways,
they were all trapped easy.
The coach used to come off slide right
off their fucking nonexistent shoulders.
So anyways,
we would start with that shit and then
we would maybe get to the war of 18, 12
never fucked with the civil war
as far as where I went to school.
We never fucked with it. It was just
our country fighting each other. Why,
why would that be of interest to anybody?
You know,
maybe that was just
northern as being cool.
You don't not talking shit after winning.
Ah,
we don't need to teach him that we won.
Right.
But down south they were
always talking about it.
Probably saying that we cheated, you
know, like people hate the Patriots.
Say we under inflated our fucking cannon
balls at whatever the fuck they're
going to say, you know. Um,
anyways, let me a tell me, just sent
me a text at Aaron Rodgers. Get hurt.
Please tell me. I fucking hate
when that happens. Roger is done.
He grabbed that niece so
fast. It's bad. Oh No.
Oh
Jesus Christ.
I fucking hate you.
It's just,
there's nothing worse than that.
You know what I mean?
And I gotta tell you something.
If you're a vikings fan or a bears
fan in your psych that that happened,
you're a fucking asshole.
You know,
I never rooted for Derek Jeter to get
hurt or any of that shit. You want a,
you want to play in when the, when do
you want to beat him with that best? Um,
wow.
Does that change the NFC?
My buddy who actually knows
something about football was,
was picking them to go to the Superbowl.
Well,
you know what that reminds me, I remember
that year when the jets were favored,
was like the first game of the season
Test Verde, you know, blew out as Achilles
and uh,
who cried? It wasn't Terrell
Owens. It was uh, the guy from USC.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Just give me the damn ball.
When did wide the wide receiver
position become the diva position.
He used to always be the quarterback.
He was the guy always walking around
with the big inflated fucking ego in
somewhere in the last like 15,
20 years.
Like all the emotional meltdowns come
from the guys who like catch the balls,
you know,
that was my quarterback.
Okay.
Um,
just give me the Damn Paul.
Oh Jesus Christ. Anyways, um,
so I worked up in Thunder Valley
learned or valley fucking California.
Um, the, the farthest north.
I have been in Sacramento.
All right.
I was a,
I landed in Sacramento was a
30 minute drive and this guy,
fortunately he took like the back roads,
which is really cool.
So we went by all these,
these farms and uh,
I actually for the first
time saw an almond tree.
I thought nuts came from the ground,
you know,
cause I always, you know, I was going to
baseball whenever I go to baseball game,
they give you the ones that
they feed to the elephants.
Those are like the fucking, you
know, the Budweiser of peanuts.
Almonds is sort of like the blue moon.
You get a little more fucking crafty beer.
Kind of snobby. Right? But they're
those, those elephant ones,
they always seem like they're dirty.
Take me out to the ball game.
I didn't know that nuts came on trees.
I'm probably making an ass of myself
right now either. They all do.
Well that's the one that does or whatever.
But I know there's a lot of you
right now just racing to look up this
information so then you
can tell me how dumb I am.
Or maybe you fucking know that.
You know,
you don't know how to grow one.
You don't know where to pick it.
You just know where it
comes from. Right. Um,
so now all of a sudden I'm the biggest
asshole ever is, is that what happened?
No belt.
You're the biggest asshole ever because
you just had a meltdown about a fucking
wire. Fair enough. Fair enough.
Jesus Christ,
the Buccaneers in saints 48 to 40.
I got to tell you before
it's all said and done,
I drew Brees is going to throw for
more fucking everything that anybody,
unless Tom Brady keeps playing.
Cause I don't think drew Brees is
doing that. Uh, drew versus time.
Tom Brady versus time like that
shit. Like today, they actually,
they said he was the oldest quarterback
to throw a touchdown in the first game
of the year.
Other than George Blanda.
Who is the Gordy fucking how of of
football as far as how long he played and,
and Warren Moon. Who? I didn't know.
I didn't know he played that late.
I know he's spent most of at least
half his career up in the CFL.
Maybe that's why he didn't seem like he
was at old because by the time he came
in the league, it was already
like eight years in the CFL. Um,
anyways, uh, why do I have the
fucking TV on? Why do I give a shit?
Should I hit pause? Let me hit pause.
You know, at the end of the day,
I have a job here to do and it's God
damn it is to make people laugh. Well,
you know what, it's a new TV and I
don't know how to do it. Is this, do it?
Oh my God, it did it. I hit
the pause button and it paused.
Fuck that.
I'm hitting play.
I still have that thing.
You remember the old days when you pause
your flat screen and then it's just
burned in there? Whatever the
fuck you were looking at. Um,
all right, let me look the other
way. Okay. So I, I watched, uh,
won't you be my neighbor?
And then I also watched a Chappaquiddick
you got to check both. Both those
movies out were incredible and uh,
any on me stay on track
here. So we took the, uh,
the back roads up to this casino,
what their thunder bay,
not to bay, sorry. Thunder Valley.
And uh,
you know,
every once in awhile I'll actually watch
the news and whenever I watched the
news,
it always puts me into a panic and
makes me feel like I should live in the
middle of nowhere next to a
lake with a bunch of guns.
You know?
And I know there's a lot of people in the
cities probably think that stuff. Okay,
well,
here's the deal.
The only way to live in the middle of
nowhere is if you grew up in the middle of
nowhere. Cause then you know
how to live out there. Right.
You came from a family that,
that taught you how to
hunt and all of that shit.
You know what I mean?
I'm too fucking old for that.
I gotta go this snake Pliska
en route and try to stay in,
in a fucking city.
You know,
I think I'm going to join the people
that live underground in the sewers cause
it's going to be so fucking hot. You
know the red heads, all us red heads,
we're going to end up under ground and
we're going to be coming up like a bunch
of filthy Malakai's.
So you guys better sharpen your fucking
swords or whatever the hell you're going
to have once you run out of bullets.
That's going to be the thing when
you run out of fucking bullets,
then it'll be swords
and just clubs and it's,
it's going to be come fucking Braveheart,
you know?
But not if we were all like Fred Rogers.
He be just sitting there
in the middle of it.
It's such a good failing to know you're
alive and when you crawl up Adda that
manhole.
I would appreciate it if you,
what the fuck just happened?
He got all of that one.
How did it go from two other here?
Three run fucking homer.
I don't even know who did it.
Very nice. That's right. Houston.
How does it feel to be owned
chain and people do that shit? Um,
the big story here is that the Houston
Astros are going to take two out of three,
which this is a series.
Now this is one of these wants that I
pay attention to because we're going to
run into these. Some bitches come October,
so I want to see how we match up my,
granted Chris sale's done in there.
I don't know if price pitched, I don't
even know what the fuck's going on.
So anyways,
we get up there to thunder valley and
it is literally a fucking casino just
surrounded by farmland and the Gig.
It's this giant stage just like
out in the parking lot and ever.
Nobody's covered. Right? If
there was any sort of rain,
I was joking like everybody would
just fucking leave and I would be
contractually obligated to do an hour in
front of a bunch of plastic wet folding
chairs.
But I gotta tell you it's one of my
favorite gigs I've had in a long time was
amazing.
The Sky was beautiful.
The only thing that was weird was
like when motorcycles would go by,
I had to like stop doing my act.
Like I was literally getting like
heckled by those things that I was joking
about. How those people up there,
they probably don't wear helmets.
You know what I mean?
Anytime you have a problem you just
drive off into a bunch of snow peas.
Those things are probably nice
and soft, slow you down. Um,
and then after that I woke up the next
morning at like something ridiculous.
I want to say it was a
4:00 AM
am and then I had to get on a 6:00
AM flight, something like that.
I can't even fucking remember.
Slide is salt lake city and from Salt
Lake City go to Toronto for tiff.
The Toronto International Film Festival
is All freckles is in a movie called the
front runner directed by,
uh,
Jason Reitman starring a Hugh Jackman.
And I just,
uh Huh.
I saw it for the first time anyways,
let me tell you the whole fucking story.
So I, one of my favorite
things I've seen in an airport
standing in line, right, trying to find
something healthy but you can't really do.
And uh, this guy in front of me,
he orders two bagels and he goes,
can you put butter on it? Can you put,
I just want to bagels with butter on it.
And he's like already on his tip toes,
like over the counter and he's tall
enough to see over the counter.
So I was like, what? He's
one of these fucking guys,
like when you prepare his food,
he has all these fucking instructions
and he's on his tip toes watching you do
it.
And immediately I'm just like,
God bless the fucking woman
or man romantically linked
to this fucking lunatic,
right?
So he's on,
he's on his tip toes at Yankee.
He's on his fucking tip
toes watching this lady.
She sticks it in the little fucking
conveyor belt piece of shit,
toaster and it comes out.
She's putting into to gaze go.
I could keep put cake with the butter on
it, ma'am. Could you just put the punch?
She goes, what? She goes, can can, can
you put the butter on? She goes, yeah.
She goes to butters over
there and he goes, no.
I was just hoping that you could put
butter on it while it's still hot so to
like melt. Can you do that? Can,
can you just put butter on it while
it's still hot and then close it up.
Can you do that for me? She
just looks at him. He goes, no,
just handed on the bag. Now I
know. I've always made fun of that.
I hate those fucking places where all
of a sudden you got to finish making the
sandwich like you work there for free,
but just the way she just told the guy
no and he was already annoying me the way
he was up on his fucking tip toes.
Okay.
Like Gee, what? What the fuck
you, you didn't order like a,
I'm trying to think of something fancy.
You wanted a fucking Bagel.
Okay.
She's going to toast the thing.
She's going to stick it in a bag.
You're gonna pay for it. Then you're
going to go over to the condiments.
Try to find something that wasn't
sneezed on. You know how it's going down.
So I laughed and she looked at me and
gave me like half a smile. She's like,
what do you want? I'm just like, ah,
I'll take one of those ham and
cheese sandwiches. You know,
you don't have to do anything to it.
MMM [inaudible]
Oh, it was great watching that guy
gets shut down. I don't know why.
It's like you have a see a little spoiled
fucking Brat kid crying, you know,
cause he wants something.
Is there anything better watching a parent
not cave and then the kid doesn't get
it.
I fee I live
for that moment when the kid cries and
cries and cries and then the parents end
up just giving it to them.
I was mixed. We just want to
like trip them. Isn't that
stupid? I don't, obviously,
I'm just saying, you know something I
do think about, I'm not proud of it.
We all have our flaws
occasionally. Yes, I see.
I see. I see a kid gets up
to and after crying and uh,
makes you want to triple and it's
stupid because the kid doesn't have the
emotional maturity to express himself.
Right?
Yeah.
What else Fred Rogers would have handled
that if he didn't want them to have it.
Why are you crying?
Well, you can't have all, my God,
what a fucking moron. This, this,
I've got blessed it. There's a woman
there, she's wearing a Houston Astros fan.
She's wearing like one of those, you know,
they make the number ones finger out.
She's got a giant orange Astros hat.
Like to the point you're blocking
people's view behind you.
Those are the things.
It's because of hats like that and people
like that. That where I'm at games.
That's one of the reasons why like things
like flame throwers are not legal to
the general public because that's the
kind of thing when you sit there for nine
fucking innings. All right. And
that's self centered content.
Won't take the fucking thing off. That's
one of the things, if you had like a, a,
a handheld,
I'm not saying you'd burn her,
but you'd like to hat on fire
and God knows what that's
made out of and it might,
you know,
touch somebody else's fucking hat and
then they're on fire and you're like,
but no, no, no. I just wanted to set
her on fire. I'm sorry sir. My Bet.
My Bet. Would you like me to
drive you to the burn unit? No.
Most of your ear is still attached.
MMM.
Anyways,
so then I flew up to Canada and I checked
like 9 million times that I had my
passport because that's one of
the things I always, you know,
the first half of my career,
you could just go to Canada,
like you're going to your friend's house.
He didn't need a passport, you know,
and then after nine,
11,
shit,
don't even say nine 11 but horrific event.
And, uh, ever since then you've hit,
you've got to have your fucking
passport to go everywhere. So, uh,
I checked like fucking 900 times,
make sure I have my passport. Um,
and I went through the customs and
everything and I think I got there at like
four o'clock. And then like
the pickup was like at five 15.
So by the time I got through customs and
all of that shit ordered room service
and everything,
like I had time to iron my stupid shirt
and then I went over there and I did the
whole, uh, you know,
the whole red carpet got
asked great questions.
Nobody tried to corner me,
you know, it was a couple of,
how would you relate this movie to
what's going on today in the current
political climate? You know,
it was fine. There was no way.
What do you think about this guy going
back on stage already knew what I was
going to say.
Well what do you think about it?
That's all I am ever do. You asked me
one of those and your career questions,
I just throw it right back at you. What
do you think about it? No, I'm asking you.
Well I didn't ask the question.
You're the one who has the question.
You're the one thinking about it. What do
you think about it? I want to hear why,
why you put a quote on it.
What do you think about it there?
They have fucking, uh,
Jimmy Olsen. So then we, uh,
I went into the,
uh,
this beautiful theater and sat down and
watched the movie and I gotta tell you,
man, it's pretty fucking incredible.
Uh, Jason Reitman killed it.
Uh, it's called the front
runner and I would not be, I
don't want to Jinx Eddie a,
I'm not going to jinx nothing,
but I would not be surprised.
I'll go real.
I'm going to really
go low here if it performs very well,
that's,
that's as much shit as I'm going
to talk. Um, but it's a phenomenal,
phenomenal movie. And the way
the whole thing was cut together,
the way they told the story. And
uh, it's really, really fascinating.
It's about the, uh, the Gary Hart story,
which a, for you youngsters out there.
He was a guy running for
president in 1988. And yes,
he was the front runner.
Great Looking Guy.
Guys like them ladies loved them.
Full head of hair,
you know, that's the kind of shit
that gets you elected. Right?
Play the saxophone on our Sineal hall.
Two terms,
not one, two terms. Ah, Shit.
Did they just hit a fucking home run guy?
That was a monster shot. Five to two.
The Astros'. No, quint numb. You
know why? Cause they're champions.
Um, oh man, that's that fucking guy.
What is his name? That's the
guy last year, the world series.
That was incredible. You know the
dude that I was out today, right?
That guy, that guy's worst. Every
time you pay him, you know, outside,
like I liked that guy in the infield
for the Texas Rangers. Total winner.
The guy who punched that dude in
the face. Um, credible ballplayer,
man,
that's going to be ashamed watching the
red sox and Yankees by him away from the
Rangers. Although back in the day, the
range of spent all money on a Rod, right?
220 million bucks. So they
got money. That's Texas, man.
You sit in on all that fucking oil.
Why don't you take some of that money,
put it on your team.
Um,
anyways,
so I got there went thank
God every like the, uh,
I got there on time and I got
to see movies. Phenomenal.
Everybody in it is so fucking good.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I had my head down whenever he,
my boys put my head down. But uh,
you know,
I watched,
I actually watched most of my scenes and
I wasn't cringing too badly. So I think,
uh, I think I did all right in it. Uh,
but I want to thank everybody for uh,
everyone I worked with and giving
me the opportunity to be in it.
But I think it's going to be a great
one. So guys, could you do me a favor?
I know you're all stream and shit.
I know you got your fucking virtual
reality glasses with your laser disc
players. Whatever the fuck
he kids are doing nowadays.
Could you just go old school,
just go to the movies when it comes up?
Just go see this thing.
Alright.
Do it for me to it for me.
So one day I can afford to buy speaker
wires that actually microphone wires that
actually work. Okay. It's for
a cost. This is a startup.
I think it comes out in
November. Um, go see it.
You will not be disappointed there.
That's it. All right. Plowing ahead.
All the gay rod, a rods in the fucking box
deck. There's another guy, another guy,
Tony Romo and Alex Rodriguez.
I say,
well they're the two best former athletes
turned broadcasters in a long goddamn
time.
It's unreal how in a rod was a player in
the New York media would be asking them
all those questions. He could get like
tongue tied. You get them in the booth
and he's just the effortless
fucking effortless. All right. Speaking of
effortless, not effortless, I should say.
I got to do some reads here for the week
and I forgot to turn the God damn line
on
there. No, you can read. Ah,
Jesus. So anyways, and then
this morning I had a 6:00 AM
6:00 AM flight. What was awesome,
there was nobody in Toronto.
I've gotten some of the worst traffic
other than La and Chicago and some of
those other fucking places,
but Toronto is just brutal traffic.
And I woke up this morning
and there was nothing,
nobody out there on a Sunday morning.
And uh,
went right through customs,
thing of beauty.
And then I went to go buy some fucking
Cuban cigars there and their prices were
out fucking religious
dude.
I was looking at, I was looking at a box
of them. They want to like 560 bucks.
It's like, dude, I can get
these things and I don't,
people in la got these things
not paying all that money.
So ended up buying that. These, these
look these little ones about like five.
I even know what the hell you call it
out. Shit. Now they fucking hitting us.
Now they're hitting somebody else.
How many outs here to top
of the six and a game?
You guys already know the
results of its five to two.
This has never been good other than the
fact that one time when the guy ran the
ball back to win the game,
that was the only time this was a good
move to have the fucking game on. Um,
all right, let me read some of the, um,
all right, let me read some of the, uh,
advertising here. Oh my
bookie, everybody, you know,
ever since I started this podcast,
people have been asking me for advice.
Ask me what team to bet on.
I don't know if he ever asked me that.
You guys did ask me back
in the day who I liked,
who I thought I was going to the both. The
truth is, I don't know who's gonna win,
but if you think you know,
you gotta check out my bookie.
Remember who you're betting on is just
as important as who you're betting with.
That's why, uh, you
need to go to my bookie.
Trust him. According to
them. They are your best bet.
This season they'd been in business fee.
Okay.
They have great reviews online and
their mobile site is easy to you.
I W I would love to read
reviews of gambling sites.
Um, well I've left me fucked his set. Um,
I would only recommend a service to my
listeners. That's been good to me. The,
the you guys, my book, you have to change
this fucking copy. Okay. I don't gamble.
All right. Well I mean I gamble with my
friends. I don't go to a site here. Okay,
you've been good to me and that you're
paying me money to read this shit.
But I mean I haven't done anything
with you guys. Okay. Anyways,
that's why evidently I'm urging
you to make your way to my bookie.
You when they pay,
that's how it works.
They have in game live betting the most
rewarding player perks in the business
and you for you fantasy guys out there,
I like this shit here.
You can even bet the over under on how
many fantasy points of player will score
each game. Join now and my book, you will
match your deposit dollar for dollar.
I like betting on stupid shit.
Coin tosses. You know what I mean?
That's like the appetizers to like
your real bet. You know what I mean?
Just to keep your fucking going anyway.
She used the Promo Code burpee
you are are to activate the offer.
Visit my bookie online today. That's
my bookie. M, Y, B, O, k, I. E.
And don't forget to use the Promo Code
[inaudible] when creating your account to
claim up to $1,000 in free
play, you play, you win,
you get paid,
or you lose and you don't get laid.
You know what I realized is that I bought
this, this fucking, uh, microphone,
wire, headphones, shit,
all this stuff and it's so heavy
that it was hanging off the table.
That's why everything actually works.
Once again,
I fucking flip out and there it was a
simple solution and there was no reason to
have a meltdown. I do
it all the time. Okay,
so now they got fucking two guys on
base. Nobody out. We got a writing,
a lefty warming up in the bullpen.
This is why the Astros won it last year.
You can not put these guys to bed,
can't talk them in.
All right? Policy Genius September is
National Life Insurance awareness month.
Most people aren't aware of that. In
fact, most people aren't aware. They neat.
Well, most people aren't fucking
away. The light turned green,
too busy staring at the God damn phones.
In fact,
most people aren't aware they
need life insurance at all.
That's why 40% of people don't have it.
Well,
I mean it's not that they're not aware
which a lot of it is guys and we don't
like dealing with our mortality.
Um, but I've, I did it.
I have my affairs in order
and I cannot tell you as,
as a husband and a father knowing that
when I Croak everybody that I love in my
family is going to be okay.
It's great.
Then you can have like a happy funeral.
You know, people show up in brand new,
uh,
black clothing
anyways, but getting life insurance
doesn't need to be difficult or expensive.
Right now prices are the lowest
they've been in 20 years.
Yeah.
Why is that?
Is it because people are living longer
and policy genius has made it easier than
ever to get covered?
Policy Genius has helped over 4 million
people shopped for insurance and placed
over $20 billion in coverage and they
don't just make life insurance easy.
They also compare disability insurance,
renter's insurance, and health insurance.
If you care about it,
they cover it.
So if you're looking for a good reason
to buy life insurance, here's three.
It's national life insurance awareness
month. That's not a good reason.
Okay. It could be national ghetto hooker
month doesn't mean you should go do it.
Right? So that one's out. Prices are
at a 20 year low. That's a good one.
And policy genius makes it easy
to get the right policy for you.
Wait, they said there was three
reasons. National Life Insurance,
wellness month prices
are at a 20 year low. Oh.
And then harassed is policy genius makes
it easy to get the right policy for you.
There you go. Uh, go to policy genius.com.
Get quotes and apply in minutes.
You can do the whole thing
on your phone right now.
Policy genius for all you dummies like me,
p.
O. L. I. S. T. Y. G. E. N. I. U.
S the easiest way to compare and buy
life insurance genius is not an easy word
to spell. It's an easy one to fuck up.
Like restaurant. That's an easy one.
Um, anyways, draft kings.
Yeah.
Uh, it's week two of the football season
visit. Well, I guess it goes, it's,
yeah, cause I'm supposed to
be reading this tomorrow. Um,
but there's still Monday night anyways,
which means a second shot at victory.
Bragging rights and huge cast prizes
are up for grabs all season long.
At draft kings, the late in one
week fantasy sports this weekend,
draft kings has over $2 million in total
prizes and you can play for free with
your first deposit to Pete for your share,
uh, with one week fantasy draft
kings, you choose when to play.
Draft a new team every week with no
seasoned long commitment. At draft kings,
you are the GM.
Just choose your players.
Stay under the salary cap and see how you,
how your team stacks up
against the competition no
matter what your skill level.
That's so fascinating. Now, you know,
they've got like the Dinero
character handicap. Each team every,
now the salary cap has to be different
for every team, right? Do they do that?
That would be fucking incredible. If they
did that and they, they'd pick the end,
you know, they picked that
perfect fucking number. C,
can't quite get all the guys you want.
That's where the skill comes in anyways.
No matter what your skill level is,
there's a contest waiting for you at
draftkings. So if you've been waiting up,
but thinking about trying
one week fantasy football,
now is the time to play because nothing
makes football Sunday more exciting than
when you put your whole
fucking paycheck down on it.
Then when you bet responsibly that when
you have a draft kings line up on the
line,
download the APP or go to draft kings.com
now use promo code burpee you are are
to enter a contest for free this weekend,
uh,
with your first deposit and compete for
your share of over $2 million in total
prices.
That's code burpee you are are at only
at draftkings Jesus the game inside the
game. Minimum $5 deposit required
eligibility restrictions apply.
See draft kings.com for details.
Um,
you know what I really miss?
I miss football cards.
That's how I knew who everybody
was in the league. I fucking
miss those things.
And what happens was all those
fucking baseball cards in the 1950s,
all the Mickey male rookie cards and all
of that shit blew up and we're with all
that money.
So by the time I became an adult,
so many adults were collecting cards.
Kids didn't give a shit about it.
And then I try collecting
football cards again and they,
they would like deliberately
make some of them rare.
You couldn't just go out and go buy a
whole set cause that's what people were
doing. And then they weren't fucking
worth anything. Let me see tops.
Let me see. They still have
these things. Football card,
Duh. Uh, 2018,
2018.
What do you got here buddy?
Will my internet work? You know
what? I don't even care if it does.
It does or it doesn't. I'm not going
to flip out about it. How about that?
Just relax bill. Just count to 10
slowly one. You know, I got a master,
I got a master going for a walk the
other day. I got into with my wife,
right. And, and I, I started to
walk away but I didn't leave,
you know.
All right. Sharp tops, football cards,
2018 football cards, release dates.
All right, let's see what they got
here. It's such a good feeling.
I used to just sit there and like,
I wouldn't study in school and I would
just look at football cards and I would
read,
I would look at the picture and I would
just read them over and over and over
again. It didn't realize it was like
flashcards. And by the end of it,
I knew everybody in the league.
I knew where they went to cook
and I would watch it every year.
I get the cards every year and
there was all these guys that I,
I already knew shit about and there
was only so many new rookies. And uh,
I remember he's still blow my dad's mind.
I was like,
and he went to college and
be, can't stay Louie couches.
See as a size 16,
quadruple ees clique.
You like Jesus Christ. How do you know
all of this stuff bill, while dad,
cause I'm not studying
all that effort that I should
have put in to my studies
so I could've gone to a big time
college, you know, and joined a Frat,
walked around, you know, maybe
join the glee club or whatever.
I've had an acapella group,
you know,
met some women,
get me two fucking years later.
I just missed out on it.
Um,
when the fuck is this thing gonna load.
All right. You know, I'm just, I'm just
going to start read some questions.
Maybe at some point I don't,
I know for the life of me,
I don't know how much money I have to
pay these Internet guys to get something
that works. You know, I was three,
I started to talk about this
where a buddy of mine had a,
you know,
he solved his internet prom but they
got these things called like mesh or
something like that where it ties the
Internet signal from one party house to
another.
And that just seems like you were in
the Tsa Line for fucking brain cancer.
Like it's bad enough.
We got all these [inaudible] it can't
be good. I don't know what it is,
but there's something going on you.
We've all done it.
We've all talked on a cell phone long
enough that like the side of your fucking
one side of your head starts
feeling weird. You know what I mean?
They still a bit about that.
So then you talk with the cell phone,
the other side of your head sort of
sear it like a fucking tuna steak.
It's just your brain. Alright,
eastern European tour. Hello Bill.
I am writing from Croatia.
I like to ask you if you are still
coming to this part of the world.
My part of the world, not
yours. Just kidding. Yes I am.
We're just working it out because a,
the dates came in and I was going to
be gone for too long. I have a kid,
so I'm trying to break it
up into two different tours.
Do a week to 10 days and then come a few
months later and do another week to 10
today. 10 10 days, 10 days, 10 days.
That's what I'm trying to do. Okay.
I promise you it is going to
happen. All right. Outdoor venues.
Uh, why did one this
weekend? So I am ready.
I'm ready for this question dear Billy.
Operation Northwoods. Look it up.
All right. Oh my internet work,
sir. I would love to look it up.
It's still loading.
Yeah.
All right. Um, thanks for the killer
show. Uh, in the casino parking lot. Oh,
thank you for showing
up. Anyways, he said,
I've heard you mentioned a
guy named law head before,
but I never knew shit about him.
Fucking hilarious guy. Yeah.
J Law had Jay lie. I, come on man,
that guy a fucking kills it on the
grill to follow him on Instagram.
You see that guy when that guy
starts cooking, it's fucking crazy.
It's like a cooking show.
Uh,
how come he's not on Netflix or seesaw?
I think it's CSO or whatever
the fuck you guys do anyways.
Wondering if the parking lot is up
there in the weirdest outdoor venues.
You've played at a, all right.
Why isn't Jay on Netflix? Well,
or CSO went out of business.
What else is there? Hulu,
Amazon and all that. Well,
eventually it happens for
everybody. Everybody, you know,
takes people different amount
of time. You know, look,
I started in 1992 and it took me until
either 2005 or 2006 to get on Letterman.
And I went through a couple of bookers,
a couple that it was just like, yeah,
I don't like you or you get a weird,
we get a weird look as one that I got.
Well I don't think that was some
the and people, but um, yeah,
you know,
it was hilarious.
I remember years later seeing this other
generations of comedians and they were
like bitching about the book booking
process and they were like seven years in.
It's just like, well wait fucking buck up
buddy. It's going to take you another A.
Yeah.
I don't know.
But that's not how it works.
It's not how it works nowadays.
Cause now there's social media cause
now you fucking complaint and then
everybody's afraid to get in trouble
and nobody know. He just goes like, hey,
you don't have, fuck you. Oh Shit.
Wow.
Ah, it's a run. Scored two run score
two runs, go. Oh my God,
these fucking Houston Astros
are relentless looking at them.
They're all up there top of the day.
This is impressive.
This is what we've been doing,
the teams all year and now they're coming
in giving us the old right there, Fred.
Fuck.
I already know what they're saying with
the sound on that ball got up there in
the zone. I mean that thing
you want that much lower.
This is like that's right
in his wheelhouse and he
jumped all over it. His eyes,
they opened up like a kid on Christmas.
Ah,
fuck me. Um, anyways,
I love that you guys know that
the result of this Houston chance.
So I was talking all that shit like
we're gonna whip y'all fucking cities as
today.
MMM.
If there is a sportscar just because
that woman is wearing that giant stupid
fucking hat in a, in a
visitor's stadium, you know?
I mean just how many times can you
just ask to get your fucking ass kicked
before it happens?
MMM.
Anyways, yeah, so people like,
yeah. Then started whining about,
I dunno how long it takes or whatever.
Then I guess it's shortened up.
It's so fucking stupid.
[inaudible] it's particularly hard for me.
It's like,
what are you, what are you
seeing out there? Like,
here's the deal.
It might be more difficult for you,
but nobody has it easy fucking sitting
there acting like God damn fucking
Spielberg sends me a
fucking sandwich every day.
MMM.
Which would be nice if he's
listening every once in a while.
Uh,
alright. Outdoor venues. Yes. Um,
where's the weirdest venues that I've
played, outdoor venues that I played at.
I used to open up for Wynonna
Judd way back in the day and we,
uh, we did a lot of outdoor venues. Um,
you know,
when you're selling that level of tickets,
she basically was selling
so many tickets that they,
they didn't have an indoor venue
big enough so that you have,
you have to go outside at some point.
So I opened it up up for her at the,
I believe it's the del Mar race track.
I thought I told this story.
So I go down there and it's one of these
deals with it, like, hey, you know,
work clean. This is a country
crowd. These people, uh,
they don't like Carsick, which,
you know, you have to respect.
It's not my crowd. I'm opening for this
person. This is what they've created,
you know, all you young comics out
there to then go up there and, and,
and curse anyways is a, that's not a
Lenny Bruce moment that, that you're,
you're acting like a jerk off.
Cause they,
they probably told you before they even
got the Gig, you got to work clean.
So if you're not going to work clean,
don't take the Gig,
but don't say you're going to work clean
and then go up there and start talking
about your nuts or far more accurately
these days, you're fucking Twat.
Cause female comics are that
fucking Dick joke comics of today.
Some of the fucking filth that I,
I mean some of the bits it's just like,
I remember this bit except there were
Dick and balls and I was standing in a bar
trying to figure out how the fuck
am I going to follow this shit.
MMM.
Anyways, so, uh, I had to clean
it was during the day,
which actually didn't bug me because I
was psyched because I was making money.
I always loved like those gigs, like a
lot of times the newness and shit sucked.
But what was awesome was when it was over,
you had your check and you already make
money and you could maybe double up and
do another Gig or you were like done
at like a normal hours. So, um,
but that never happened. You know,
you always went out and did more fucking
time. Are we going to do sit at home,
be alone with your thoughts?
So I went down there
and Wynona was always like
really nice to me. Um,
and I went down to open up and I
got to work clean. It's outside,
I'm in the sun, I'm a redhead.
I still had my hair back then,
so I didn't need a hat and a,
I'm up there and I'm doing my shit.
And all of a sudden this lady in the crowd
who I'm going to go out on a limb and
say was a lesbian, you know, she had
that haircut, the whole fucking thing.
I know you're not,
you're not supposed to do all you need.
At least you're not supposed to
do that with lesbians. You know,
you can do that with other groups of
people. You know. Don't be a Brad,
don't be a Chad. You can, you can fucking
do that. But if you go the other way,
all of a sudden you're
an asshole. Uh, but yeah,
I mean if I had to put my life savings
on it and the same people that were
criticizing me,
if it was a life or death situation,
if you had to put money on it, you
would say this was a lesbian. Right.
Why is it pertinent to the story? Because
I'm painting a picture. All right?
And all you liberal cons out there acting
like you don't have a fucking idea in
your head when I say that,
that she was a lesbian.
You have no fucking idea what I'm saying.
What if I said it was a frat boy,
you got your boom, you got to get that
picture in your head. Right. Um, anyways,
so she sit there and I'm on
stage and she shit the whole,
like I maybe get three minutes
into my act, we'll fucking outside.
It's brewed and she's just staying
that she starts going, wow.
Wow.
And she's trying to get the rest
of the crowd to do it with her,
which they're not thankfully,
but she's fucking relentless.
And I don't know if I did a
joke that she didn't like,
or maybe it was that I had a deck.
I have no fucking idea.
Or maybe I was just an pasty you
maybe she thought I was weird looking.
Well, maybe she was just a comment.
I have no idea what she's doing that.
And I'm sitting there
and I want to go off on her,
but I got to work clean.
So I actually just stopped and I
gathered myself and I said, Hey lady.
I was like, what is the problem?
Why are you chanting wine?
Wynonna is, why no, not,
she's going to come out here
at eight 30
no matter what she's coming
out at eight 30. Okay.
Do you think I thought all you guys came
out here to see me. I know why I'm here.
I'm dancing monkey boy, but blah
blah blah blah blah. And uh,
I got the crowd on my side and then
I made fun of her haircut. I had to,
I had to do it cause I had to make sure
I got all the Trump supporters on my
side.
I was flailing and then I got him and I
started having getting laughs and that
lady was pissed and she was
still chant. Why? No, no,
but now it's drowning or out with
laughs and I was winning. Oh,
redhead in the sun with
this pasty freckled back up
against the nonexistent wall
was turning it around
and then out of nowhere the crowd went
from laughing on and know where they just
went,
Woo.
All at the same time. And I couldn't
figure what the fuck happened.
I thought my fly came down.
I had no idea.
And I turned around and behind me was a
way off in the distance was a carnival
and there's some ride where they just
shoot you up in the fucking air, like,
like superman.
So I'm standing there fucking finally
getting the crowd and right as this
starting to pay attention to me
in the way in the background.
Some guy got shot up in the fucking air
on this ride and then I kind of made fun
of that. Oh, not another hit. Ah,
another had another run scores
and we got ourselves a tie game
five to five,
just like that,
uh, coaches coming out to
the mound. Um, Jesus Christ.
Wow. And with deep into our
fucking bullpen already.
This is not looking good guys.
MMM.
Anyways, uh, so yeah,
that was a weird one.
I've done also, I've done
college gigs in a, uh,
sort of that area. You know, the
Walker's shame area between dorms.
I've done that. And it was also like
sort of a carnival thing set up.
There's always a fucking car. It was
always rides some sort of popcorn machine.
MMM.
I remember a long time ago,
this one was actually inside.
MMM.
It was me, Patrice, O'Neil,
Robert Kelly, Dane Cook, and Al Del Benny.
We all do in this gig.
And it was some,
some sort of Jewish thing.
I don't remember what was a
function hall and the crowd was,
was predominantly Jewish. I don't
know. It couldn't have been fucking,
they don't go to church.
Where do they go to temple?
I couldn't have been related to
that or they wouldn't have hired us.
I don't know what it was,
but all I know is we were up there
and
none of us were in the business long
enough to recognize like we will go,
why is this microphone so small?
Like you could hold it
with just your two fingers.
I remember our went up there first go,
and this is the smallest
microphone I've ever seen.
Then he put it in his mouth and
started humming or whatever,
and people laughed and I was like,
oh my God, I got to hold that thing.
Now I've got to go up after
him. Right. So we did the whole,
we did the whole fucking show.
I remember when Patrice got up there,
he was holding it with his
big fucking fat fingers.
Just holding this little
thing is three things.
Like he was holding a teacup and a,
it wasn't until years later when I did
my first TV Gig that I realized it was a
lapel Mike and none of us knew.
Just clip it on your shirt and then just
walk around like you're doing the one
man show, you know, with
both hands. So we all,
we would like finish our act and there
was a mic stand and we would like drape
it over and then the next guy would come
up and just pick it up with his index
finger and his thumb. Um, yeah,
I don't know. I gotta be honest
with you. All of those hell gigs,
they all just kind of, they kind of
fade away after a while. I can't,
I don't remember. I just know I've
had a bunch of shit thrown at me.
I think I just, after a while you
just, you don't want to remember him.
MMM.
Yeah. I don't know. I, I've, I've done
some, I've definitely done some weird,
I know I've done,
I did one outside up on the
fucking west side highway.
There was like boats and shit
and all these fucking flies and stuff.
Yeah.
These are all starting to come
back to and was hottest shit too.
And I was up there and I had like a long
sleeve button down cause I just worked
like a comedy club so they had like the
air conditioning cranking and then I
went over and did that Gig and I was like
sweating my ass off. Yeah, I've done it.
I've done a lot of those.
That's kind of par for
the course that happens.
Um, that was a fun one though. I opened
for Wynona outside in a, in a, uh,
in a parking lot, parking lot, race track,
the occasional theater. I opened up for
an a parking lot in Laughlin, Nevada.
Jesus do. Why are you bringing back all
of these memories? All right. A smoothie,
dear bill,
years and years back you said Kevin,
James told you the benefits of having
liquid first in the morning to get your
engine going. Kevin James. I don't
know if you get the name right.
I've only met him like once
a smoothie, water, et cetera.
Then a few years ago you basically said,
fuck that because you
thought it was too much.
It might have read it was bad for you.
Now you're doing smoothies.
Do you think it'll stick this time?
No Pun intended. Go blend yourself.
Uh, well, I didn't know how to make one
healthy back then. You know what I mean?
There's a lot of them.
It's just like you do all this stuff and
there's a bunch of sugar and shit that
you're putting in there. Um, now
that I've been using like, um,
unsweetened almond milk,
almond milk, I used to hate it.
Now I'm kind of used to it. Uh,
I got a good one for you. Uh,
one cup of almond milk.
I little am miming doing this,
putting this shit in.
Uh,
then it's like a teaspoon of cinnamon,
a frozen banana,
two tablespoons of almond,
peanut butter.
MMM.
A tablespoon of Maca powder.
Some ice,
a little bit of ice. You blend that
fucker together. It's delicious.
Tastes like a goddamn chocolate shake
and you drink it and you have energy for
hours.
MMM.
I gotta be,
I gotta be honest with you.
If I actually knew enough about
nutrition and all I could do,
if all I could do was just that
mmm.
And just do a liquid diet,
I would love to do that.
I would absolutely love to do that.
MMM.
There's another one I have that's
like Kale. It says apple juice.
That's the only thing I don't like.
It's apple juice and just apple
juice has a bunch of sugar in it.
So I went to the like, this is fucking
hilarious. It's is health food store.
But like,
they don't like gays.
Funniest fucking thing. I was like,
how did those things go together?
It's usually like, hey man, here's some
vitamins. And everybody's like, everybody,
man, uh, who the fuck would it?
Whoever saw that comment. Um,
um, so yeah, I would love
to do that. Like, uh, two,
she saw some of the shit that I'm fucking
eating. They'll look at this fucking,
I Miss Boston.
Just saw a guy,
he had a red sox like knitted cap on
with the Tom Brady Jersey in a glove
sitting right along the third
base line. Fucking hilarious. Um,
I would love to do that.
Um,
I like vegetarian and Vegan meals,
but I also still like steak,
but I know if I combined
like all of that shit,
I can still eat a little bit like
John Wayne and not have a problem.
Um, all right. You disrespected miles
Davis. You can't. All right. What is this?
Hey Bill, in season two,
episode four of F is for family.
There is an album cover parroting
the miles Davis kind of blue.
In the background of one scene
in the corner of the cover,
there appears to be a label of
blue note records in this case,
black note records.
Uh,
these two instances of factuality
are factually incorrect.
Dude, how much you fucking
jazz guys, you know,
back in the fucking day,
I used to host this show
called the jazz oasis on, on,
uh,
the fuck was it?
88.9 wers at Emerson College.
And I used to find,
I didn't know fucking anything about jazz
and I'd asked You fucking assholes to
call in requests and none of
you motherfuckers would call in.
All you would do is wait for me to play
a record and then all you fucking cunts
would get on the phone and call me and
be like, fuck you play in that four, man.
It ain't jazz. The fuck is that
dude. Ain't Jay's mother fucker.
All you fucking guys can go fuck yourself.
Go sit on your fucking horn. All right.
First of all,
did you enjoy the show?
Did you enjoy the episode?
Listen to this ass. Those are factually
incorrect. Kind of blue was released,
released on Columbia records.
Nobody likes labels,
record labels more than these fucking
jazz people and Miles Davis at the time
had not recorded for blue note in a
number of years you might want to get your
facts straight.
You believe this shit.
If you want to reference the
greatest jazz record of all time,
it may behoove you to risk respect,
possibly the greatest musician of the
20th century by simply getting some simple
factual information correct on your show.
You're dumb cunt.
Tony Williams is probably ashamed of
you. Let's be honest. All right, sir.
I'm going to walk you back through
all your bullshit. Okay? First of all,
the reason why it didn't say Bluenote or
Columbia records is because we would've
had, we would've had to
get permission to do that.
That's also the reason why the song kind
of sounded like kind of blue but wasn't
because we don't have the
fucking budget to use that music.
All right? That's why, that's
why it looked like that.
Okay, and then secondly, Tony Williams
didn't play on that record. You dumb. Fuck
I then for the record, I thought it
was Philly, Joe Jones. I looked it up.
It was like some Guy
Jimmy carb or something.
I hope I got his fucking name wrong.
Does he can blow another gasket?
Fuck all you jazz guys. You
stupid cunt. You're not,
you're not making an animated show.
You have no fucking idea how much money
music costs. That's why we did that.
Okay. We weren't disrespecting
miles Davis. Okay,
so why don't you take all your words like
behoove stick him in your clarinet and
shove it up your ass.
You pretentious fucking cunt.
Ah, did that feel good? He didn't even,
you can get the right
drummer after giving me shit.
He didn't even get the
right fucking drummer.
Tony Williams was part of the second grade
quintet. I do know that, but I don't,
I don't know shit about jazz.
But I do know that the reason why we
did that was because it would, we,
okay.
Columbia records and balloon up probably
wouldn't have given us permission.
And if they did,
it would have cost us more money than
it costs to fucking make the whole,
we would've been screwed.
That's why sir. Okay.
So we didn't disrespect them. We
tipped our fucking capital. Um,
by the way, do you play any
instrument? Are you in a
band? All right. Anger issues.
This could not come at a
better time. Anger issues. Uh,
I'm gonna have anger issues if we don't
get out of this fucking any. Oh, we did.
We finally got out of the gate.
Um,
dear Billy red top dear
bill. Bill red top. Okay.
I had anger issues when I was younger.
Oh my God.
Is this going to be a ray of light?
I had a good family but I grew up in a
neighborhood that exposed me to shit I
shouldn't have seen.
Uh,
as a defense I started
reacting to everything with
anger and it carried on into
my adult life.
Did I write this in a
drunken state and I forgot,
cause this sounds like me.
I've read lots of books and even wrote
a few unpublished ones on the topic
myself. See you actually worked
on it. I commend you for that.
Yeah.
I just like try for a few days
and then I just go back to
what I know anyways. It kept me
from being the happiest I could be.
It didn't ruin my life,
but it's kept me from enjoying things.
I had a bad habit of looking at people
who are happy and finding reasons not to
like them. Oh, I don't do that. I
think I did that in my twenties, but I,
I'm not like that. Uh, even people I was
close to, which may sound strange. Nope,
I did that a long time ago.
And then I've also had that done to me.
Um,
I remember when I bought my old truck,
68 f 100 short bed. This guy was like,
what'd you get? A truck? Huh? Okay.
You going to put stuff back there?
Just like annoyed because everybody was
looking at my truck going do that thing
is so fucking Badass. Nobody has that out
here. This thing's the shit, you know.
Anyways,
I've been catching up on your podcasts
over the last year and I've heard you go
from being much very angry to still
pretty being pretty Angalee but certainly
less angry than before. I'm
glad you've made strides. Well,
not on this podcast because I can tell
you the most important thing I gained
from reprogramming,
my immediate reaction to everything
from anger to observance is time.
Uh, I'm not smart enough to only read
that sentence once I got to do this again.
Uh, I can tell you the most
important thing I gained
from Ray crow reprogramming,
my immediate reaction to everything
from anger to observance is time.
What does that mean?
You got time back or something or you,
you're enjoying your life more because
you don't have to spend so much of it
apologizing for what you did an hour
ago. Anyways. It's sneaky though.
Being angry can waste a whole day and
you can do things while still being
agitated, but you don't feel like
you're completely unaccomplished. Yeah,
I don't, I don't stay angry for a whole
day. Uh, I just do like in spurts.
Then it goes all the way up to the top.
Then it come back down away because
what the Hell is wrong with you?
I've got your right. Sorry.
You know, I'm just trying to,
that's fucking doing my
work. Uh, you still ran your,
your errands and did your jobs
and fed your kid, is Cetera,
but you probably ignoring things you
could be doing to advance yourself.
Uh, you're likely not appreciating
those. Who are we talking about here?
Is this me? My goodness.
I've stern talking to um,
or you just a hypothetical you,
but you're probably ignoring things
you could be doing to advance yourself.
You're likely not appreciating those
around you who make your life good because
you are focused on people who make your
life terrible or projecting things on
people that aren't there.
Um,
I don't do any of that
with anybody in my life.
I do that with the people that are
in power. I do that a lot. You know,
like I was all ready to fucking talk
about everybody at best buy this is like
two podcasts in a row and
they've done nothing wrong.
It's just been me needing to make
a couple adjustments anyways.
My biggest regret in all my anger years
was snapping at people who are genuinely
good people who didn't
have that angry gene.
It's like being six foot one, two 15
kicking the hell out of a small kid.
They can't defend themselves because if
they do, they become the mania, Qr, Hor,
horrible position to put someone in.
Hope you crossed the finish line to zen?
Um, yeah. I mean, I think I'm,
I'm somewhere in the middle of
angry in Zen, believe it or not,
as much as I flip out, like
I was, I was a lot worse,
but, uh, I don't wish bad shit on people
and, um, I don't resent anybody. I don't,
I just don't want things.
Things make me freak up.
Anything tech technology
related makes me flip up or,
you know what's funny is
if I get something old,
I have all the patients in the world,
you know,
like if my old truck won't start,
I actually, you know, I mean,
I'm not going to say I enjoy it,
but I,
I find that the process of
figuring out what's wrong with it,
enjoyable and then learning,
you know,
as the truck gets fixed, what
that was, why that happened,
how to prevent it in the future. Uh,
I, uh, I tell you this, you know what,
playing drums really helped me
getting back into playing drums and,
uh,
you know, meet and Nia, having a
kid just shit that made me happy,
uh,
has kinda gotten me to that. But my big
thing is if I could just stop snapping,
that's kind of what I,
I don't walk like,
you know what's funny is people
actually think I am like an angry guy,
like a walk around angry.
I don't, I just snap.
MMM.
I'm definitely loud and I'm
definitely fucking crazy. But, uh,
I dunno, you, I'll let you guys be the,
I don't classify myself as an angry guy.
Um, I signed, I'm talking
about my drinking. Like I
don't think I'm an alcoholic.
I don't think I'm an angry guy. And I also
think that I can admit when I'm wrong,
I'll fucking mess. All right.
Dilemmas, dilemmas, clarification
number one. Uh, Bill,
last week you read my dilemma wrong.
Oh, sorry. Geez. Everybody coming at me.
Uh,
you have to either score perfectly on
the sats with up to a year of studying or
in one sitting when a game of monopoly.
Oh,
all in one city. That means
bankrupting all the other players.
Which one to save your life.
MMM. Oh, the fucking sats.
Absolutely. Those things
are, are, are pretty hard,
but fucking went in monopoly in
one sitting. I mean, that's just,
I'd rather like sit down and like this
time around really pay attention in math
class and find out what,
um,
what this math is she is applied to as
opposed to just being regurgitated at me.
Then sitting down and rolling
dice like I'm in a fucking casino,
you know, I mean, Jesus Christ.
Can you imagine, you know,
your life's on the line and you're moving
a little dog or a shoe around a board.
I think I would much rather
leave it up to my brain.
Sort of a damned if you do, damned if
you don't come on. Get underneath that.
All right. You ain't got a
challenge his arm. Okay. Okay
Man on second top of the seventh
one out. Okay. Dear Bill,
dear, dear bill to thought
I have a dilemma for you,
would you rather have to
fight an alligator in a water
tank with a 12 inch blade
or fight an alligator in a room with
a 30 inch aluminum baseball bat?
All right, well we haven't talked
about the size of the alligator.
I'm assuming it's big
enough to kill me obviously.
Well I remember a long time ago,
I'm a cop told me if you're not going to
get a gun to get a bet because you want
to have distance between
you and the intruder.
So considering the intruder is
a fucking reptile pass ball,
he goes to third.
Yeah.
Fuck. Um, I would uh,
yeah,
I take the the baseball bat and the weird
thing about an alligator is you got to
come at them straight on.
Right? Or from behind.
Okay.
Those fucking things. You don't
want to be on the side. They, they,
they bite from the side.
If you're right in front of him,
you're all good.
That's why all those,
those fucking morons that go up
and they stick their, their, their,
their arm and the guy's mouth.
The guy.
No fucking way.
Holy Shit.
What a fucking play that was,
dude. Lay down a bunt. That l to bay
guy came in. Who the fuck was that?
Zander Bogart too. Through that
fucking ball. Who? True that ball. Oh,
wasn't who he swung actually. Actually
it wasn't a good throw. He got him
throw was high. He slid wide. Oh No,
they're going to reverse
that ladies and gentlemen.
Ah, you mother fucker. That's going
to be that. He's safe anyways. Yeah,
I would, I would 30 inch aluminum
bat. Wait. Yeah. Wait a minute.
That's not that big.
It's only three feet.
MMM.
All right.
This is just is so weird.
I would attack the top
of his head from behind,
but I'd start with this feat.
All right.
You know that would actually fucking
kill me to do that to a living thing like
that. I'd have to fucking slowly chop it
down. I had attacked the fuck things fee,
although I did see that
one with that fuck on.
Rogan showed that with that alligator bit,
the other ones leg and
just did the death row,
rip the fucking things leg off and
the other one wasn't going like,
so it was just going like,
let's,
it just fucking down a barely bled.
So yeah, I think, I
think you just got to a,
I mean what I really love to do is just
sort of somehow getting on its back,
rub its belly. Oh, I know when I would do,
I'd take my shirt off
and I'd cover its eyes.
I've seen those guys do that.
And then I would take that
fucking bat and I would just,
why am right down on his fucking, you
know, I, I, you know, that would be it.
I would want to kill an alligator.
I am terrified of those things,
but I don't live in the same world.
It does. But if it was me or him,
I mean that thing has to go.
MMM.
I've eaten alligator though. Night
alligator. When I was in Florida,
it was fucking gross.
Just too Goddamn Gamey.
People like guy, you know, it tastes
like chicken. It doesn't, it doesn't.
Chicken is fucking delicious.
Steers are delicious.
Those are the in pigs are delicious.
Those are the three fucking best
tasting things. Turkeys are good.
They dry out though.
You know,
that's what I think. Like if you
get to the upper level of, you know,
if you have a smoker,
if you actually know how to smoke Turkey,
how to fuck did I do an
hour and 20 minutes? I'm all
right. That's the podcast.
I really appreciate people that tried to
help me with my temper because I would
like, I mean, I, I need to learn to
like how to stop fucking snapping.
Um, that's the big thing. You
know, I'm not going to lie to you.
I do ramp it up a little bit when I'm on
the podcast just to entertain you guys.
But, uh, that is, that was pretty
legit earlier in this show. All right,
that's the podcast here.
I'll check in on you on, um,
on Thursday.
Go fuck yourselves at a,
I have a wonderful couple of days.